[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every four years with the Olympics
municipalities compete to host the
winter and summer games and virtually
always plunge their cities and sometimes
even their home countries into massive
debt and insolvency why because host
cities inevitably spend double or more
of our initial estimates fewer people
show up than expected in the
International Olympic Committee or IOC
takes bigger and bigger cuts of TV and
other revenue streams sports economist
Andrew Zimbalist says that a typical
Summer Olympics generates up to six
billion dollars in revenue at least half
of which goes to the IOC
Winter Games generate even less money
despite often being more expensive to
host than Summer Games cities routinely
claim that whatever money they spend on
new facilities will stimulate the local
economy for decades to come with the
recent announcement that Paris will host
the 2024 Summer Games and Los Angeles
will host the 2028 Summer Games
here are five cities that got [ __ ] by
hosting the Olympics Athens is the
birthplace of the ancient games that
inspired today's modern municipal money
pets its 2004 games cost sixteen billion
dollars or ten times the original
estimate by 2010 more than half the
venue's built for the event were
underused completely empty or literally
falling apart at 50 billion dollars the
Sochi Winter Games cost more than all
previous Winter Olympics combined paid
for by a dwindling supply of Russian
petrodollars and gold bullion Boris
Nemtsov documented that 21 billion
dollars went for embezzlement and
kickbacks for businessman Friends of
Vladimir Putin Nemtsov was later
assassinated
[Music]
played by low ticket sales partly due to
the outbreak of the Zika virus the Brio
games ended up costing twenty billion
dollars rather than the thirteen billion
dollars backers claimed and the
showplace Maracana stadium which got a
five hundred million dollar makeover was
largely abandoned soon after the games
and has had thousands of seats ripped
out by vandals the Beijing Games cost 42
billion dollars a record at the time
even though Amnesty International
charged that the Chinese government used
forced labor to build many of the
venue's the IOC didn't mind the
stratospheric costs or the crackdowns on
dissent though it awarded Beijing the
2022 Winter Games the mayor of Montreal
declared that the Olympics can no more
have a deficit than a man can have a
baby unfortunately it took Montreal 30
years to pay off its debt just for the
main stadium built for the 1976 games if
there's good news here it's that city
seemed to be wising up Harrison Los
Angeles were the only two cities to bid
on the 2024 Olympics and the IOC was so
anxious that there wouldn't be enough
applications for 2028 that it
preemptively awarded them to LA but just
like with professional sports teams that
extort tax dollars and subsidies for
stadiums that never pay back their
inflated costs it's likely the Olympics
will keep finding new suckers for one of
the oldest scams in sports
[Applause]
[Music]